us so todoris is one of the organizers
of the semester already so thank you so
much for that
um he is an assistant professor of
operations manage oppression management
at mit sloan
his work is really interesting because
it spans both economics and algorithmic
economics in particular and machine
learning and i think the way he thinks
about you know data-driven processes
really nicely bridges in between these
two areas which i think is a very timely
type of research
and todoris is here for the entire
semester so you have a lot of chance to
talk with them
this talk is going to be about how to
bridge between the last two talks we saw
which were about sarcastic and
adversarial bandits thank you
thank you and thanks everybody for
staying until now so in this talk uh we
are going to take the two previous talks
and we are going to discuss how one can
interpolate between the two and how one
can breed the techniques that we
discussed before
so the general setting is again a
multi-unbanded setting
where you have uh
your the setting
works
sequentially over capital t rounds and
at the beginning of the round the
learner needs to select a probability
distribution of those a set of k arms
and uh each arm gets a reward and we're
going to specify how the reward
is where the reward is coming from
afterwards
subsequently once the rewards are
generated
and let the learner randomly draws an
action from the probability distribution
that they committed to so a of t is the
action that we are selecting and p of t
is this probability distribution
and then we are earning the reward for
the action that we selected so we are
earning reward of
r of 80 of t
and we receive what's called the banded
feedback where essentially we only
observe the reward for the action that
we selected but we do not see what would
have happened how do we selected
different taxes
now what did these cybrats tell us cypra
told us what happens when the rewards
come iid from fixed distributions that
depend on the arm a but are not changing
over time so there is a fixed
distribution for each arm this is called
f of a and at every time step t the
reward that we are getting for rmt is
drone iid from this fixed distribution
what hypene told us
was
the situation when this step two
the way that the rewards are generated
are coming from an adaptive adversary
where the rewards can implicitly depend
on the entire history and by history i
mean both
the algorithm of course that the learner
is using but also possibly previous
rewards for all the arms not only the
ones that were selected
and also realized realized actions that
that the
the
learner
selected
so
in the one case the rewards come from a
fixed distribution that does not change
around over time in the other case the
rewards are a function of the entire
history
now
in this talk we're going to try to
breathe the two so we have a nice brace
here between the stochastic and the
adversarial case and we're going to
discuss how one can think about trying
to interpolate between the two
in particular we're going to address
three questions
the first question
is what is called the best of both
worlds
how can one derive
a single algorithm that simultaneously
attains the stochastic guarantee
if the input happens to be iid and
stochastic while also attaining the
adversarial guarantee
if the input happens does not happen to
be a id and therefore it is non-ied or
other circuit
in particular we're going to discuss two
different approaches to think about that
the one is starting from stochastic
algorithm and tries to robustify that
while the other one starts from an
adversarial algorithm and try to do a
more optimistic exploration to be able
to achieve this enhanced guarantees uh
when the input turns out being iab
so this is the first question and this
will be the first part of the talk
subsequently we are going to go to the
topic of the talk which is the bridging
the two worlds and we're going to
discuss what are models that allow us to
interpolate between the stochastic and
the adversarial extremes
and subsequently in particular we're
going to also discuss what are
algorithmic design principles that can
adapt to the difficulty that this
particular setting has
and particularly i will
discuss three different ways to
interpolate between these three these
two extremes and i will mostly focus on
the one that uh
having already discussed adversarial
corruption but i will also briefly
mention two other ways that one can
think about interpolating between
stochastic and adversarial
the last question that we're going to
address is how can we take now the
design principles that we designed for
multi-arm bandits
and
extend them to apply to settings that
are beyond multi advantage
and
for example the two settings where that
have more complexity goal structures or
more complex feedback structures when
you don't
it's not that you just receive banded
feedback maybe it's a more complicated
feedback to what you're receiving we're
kind of going to try to understand how
we can use lessons from bandits to
address
other settings in the spirit also of
what cipra discussed
and the hype interests on in the last
stock
so this is this is the plan
so let's start first of all uh
by defining what is regret people have
both zipline hype and have already
covered that so i will be quick
typically what you care
in
sequential decision making is that you
would like to maximize your your
cumulative rewards
so the goal that you have is that you
would like to get as much reward as
possible
now on its own this quantity does not
really help you to to understand how
well your algorithm is doing
if you now see another as reward that is
0.5 you don't know whether it is the
case that any arm that you would have
selected has 0.5 but there are better
arms of that or whether you really was
able to identify the best arm that has
this average 0.5
as a result the notion of regret tries
to compare the benchmark and hypen
provided a very nice discussion about
this the definition of regret when it
makes sense when it doesn't
but generally regret what it
does is selects us benchmark the best
fixed action height set
so
at the end of the game you should not
look back and regret the fact that you
did not use
a single best a single action throughout
the whole
time
now
this compares to hindsight optimum it
obviously depends on the realized
records as i stated is a random variable
that depends on the realized reports
and also depends on the algorithm that
there's our banded case because the
rewards as we said in function of the
entire history now another notion that
is used often is what is called the
pseudo regret that rather than comparing
to the reward the exposed or hindsight
reward of the best action
it compares uh to the exante optimal
action
so both the stochastic and the
adversarial case one can think about one
can evaluate
if they know exactly what
the regard the generating process one
can evaluate what is the what action has
the highest expected reward should
regret compares the expected performance
of the algorithm to the expected
performance of the record of the arm
that has the highest uh
the highest
expect the highest mean
in uh x examiner
so and again i should say that this
still depends on the algorithm because
as i've nicely discussed
the rewards are a function in
adversarial settings the rewards are the
functions as a function of the algorithm
uh so that's a useful thing to keep in
mind
okay
so with that now that we have defined
the regret let's move the two words
so in the stochastic bandit gold as we
said
there goes our id for each arm so each
arm has a fixed distribution fa the
words are drawn from this fixed
distribution
an example that you can think for that
is online advertising
so you can think of the arms that we
have been discussing
as alternative
ads
that you may want to select if you are
google or meta or bing
for a particular query
and now the reward has to do with the
click probability what is the
probability that uh
what is the likelihood that if you
display a particular ad this will is
going to result to a click and if you
think about pay-per-click auctions this
will mean that the platform is going to
get revenue
and the mean in this case is what's
called the click-through rate which is
the probability that
a particular display will result to
click
so as zebra discussed there are multiple
algorithms for this case separate focus
on ucb and thomson sampling there's also
a very nice algorithm that's called
successive elimination that we are going
to discuss in this talk because it'll it
will allow us to to do a more easy easy
bridging towards the adversarial case
it's very similar with ucb and i will
discuss it afterwards so these are some
examples and the type of guarantees that
we are getting us so sible said is
essentially something like logarithmic
over the gap
there is a subtlety between the pseudo
greg that you get
exactly what uh cipra discussed for high
probability you will get the minimum of
this log over gap and the square root of
t because if the arms are really close
to each other you will have some
fluctuations and you will not be able to
avoid the square root of t in this case
now in the other extreme when we go to
adversarial advantage i can remember
that very wars now are a function of the
entire history
and an example that you can think as
hypen talk discussed before is learning
games so if you play against other
agents then you cannot really assume
that their behavior is going to be
completely iid they may try to use
whatever you did against for example so
it can even be adversarial but
definitely it's not completely id so the
adversarial setting is
definitely is is uh
well motivated in in such settings where
you expect
that there will be reactive behavior
from
uh from uh against based on what you're
doing adaptive adversarial case
now algorithms in this case as a hyphen
discussed are xp3 that's
the one that
uses
ftrl with negative synonym entropy the
challenging algorithm that hyphen
briefly uh mentioned that at achieving
the min max a guarantee for though that
there's an abandoned case and also the
barrier that we discussed uh
before us giving
a small loss guarantee
and having all the other nice properties
that
in extending in other settings
now the performance grant in this case
is the case is that you get square root
of kt so the regret and uh for high
probability regret i'm actually not
completely sure whether you can get
spirit of kt without the logarithm
but
you definitely can get square root of kt
times log t
but yeah
cool okay
so
uh so that's the two settings the two
words now
what we are the first question that
we're going to address is uh the best of
both worlds question remember the best
of both worlds question says
that you want a single algorithm that
simultaneously will achieve the
stochastic guarantee if the input is iid
and also achieves the adversarial
guarantee if the input is not ideal
as i said there are two approaches
it's the stochastic based approach that
essentially starts by running a
stochastic bonded algorithm
and occasionally tests whether
stochasticity still holds
now if the test is failing at every any
particular point if the test fails
then this algorithm switched to an
adversarial bandwidth guarantee
algorithm
so that's the one approach and we're
going to discuss that the other approach
is that versailles based approaches has
run an adversarial based algorithm
and they use different ways in order to
be able to achieve enhanced performance
if they input this iid for example one
particular way that you can use is to
adapt your exploration based on the
empirical gap so if you have seen that
an algorithm has been significantly
worse than another then you
play that less
you you adapt your you have a larger
learning rate for example in this case
or some different exploration parameter
okay cool
so let's uh start with stochastic based
approach
so in the stochastic based approach so
we have
uh
one one algorithm that is used
is uh for example successive elimination
this is an algorithm by evan dahl
manor mansour and uh uh and master
glr06
so we have two arms the one arm has the
mean 0.4 and the other arm has mean 0.6
so and what we do is that we keep a set
of active arms at every time
initially all the arms are active but as
the algorithm will will proceed we are
going to deactivate some of the others
similarly because what zebra said we are
going to keep a confidence interval uh
around its arm because as we said the
greedy approaches will
be will fail typically so you are going
to keep a confidence interval around the
mean
around the empirical mean of the arm so
by the green here is the empirical mean
and you keep a confidence interval
you add and subtract a bonus to ensure
that with high probability the actual
mean will be inside
this now how the algorithm works is that
at any point it selects an active
uniformity at random when you select an
active arm the confidence interval
shrinks because if you see how the bonus
is defined it has in the denominator it
has the number of times that you have
selected but it's similar with what we
saw in dcp
and what once an arm is is dominated by
another arm so once the upper confidence
bound of arm 1 is below the lower
confidence boundary part 2 we're going
to eliminate or deactivate this
particular arm and we're going to remove
it from the
arms
now the cracks of the analysis similar
to you with ucb with hydroability the
actual mean of the confidence interval
is always within the confidence interval
by concentration bound by the similar
shafting a bounce for example that
zipline discussed
and one can show
similarly as in ucb that you're not yet
any suboptimal alarm is going to be
deactivated after log t over gap squared
rounds
and this means that you're going to get
log t over gap square times gap because
every time that you're selecting this
suboptimal alarm uh you you get this
about multi-gap
which is the difference between the
optimal mean and the mean of this arm
and therefore you get this look t over
gap regret currently
now
the stochastic based best of what goals
approaches start with successive
elimination
and what for example the original paper
of bubak and slivkins that introduced
the setting this question of best of
both worlds
did was that they ran successful
elimination and at any point in that
what they did that for deactivated arms
they randomly tested if the rewards are
consistent with the confidence interval
so what can happen here is that after
some time you deactivated some arm this
arm may have been
the
the arm that is the best arm because the
input is adversarial for example
and therefore you're going to test to
make sure that whatever you have seen
before is still a representative for for
what you
for what is the performance of the arm
and
if not you if the if the test fails so
if you detect known stochasticity then
you're going to switch to
xb3.peak which is a high probability
adversarial temperatures
the guarantee that this gives is k log
squared t over gap pseudo stochastic
should i regret and also a square root
of kt
this is square root of kt for the
adversarial for the adversary
now
in designing the tests the the main
faculty is that you need to make sure
that the tests are not too frequently
too frequent because if you are testing
too often you will lose the algorithmic
granting you don't want to select
suboptimal alarms very often if it is
the case that the input is stochastic
the whole point is that you only going
to get logarithmic guarantee in that
case but also they should not be very
infrequent
in frequent either because if
you detect the nonstochasticity after
you have already lost square root of t
then you're not going to achieve square
root of of the afternoons
so you need to make sure that you need
to balance the two essentially
and that's the main challenge in this in
this case and the the design of the
testing
that the boob against liberty study is
doing tries to balance those two
now subsequently there was a paper by
our peter rauer and xiang
who it's uh
it's provided an
alternative version which is called the
stochastic universal pseudo alternative
sapo rather than sao as before
that so that in fact one cannot improve
on this log square t
unless you get a linear regret in the
adversarial case so that if you care
about high probability guarantees this
dependence this log squared independence
is unimproved but
that said what they did is that they
designed an algorithm that had
an adversarial pseudoregulated guarantee
of square root of kt and a log t
guarantee for the stochastic
pseudoregret
and the key idea in their case in order
to improve this will look fair to log
was to use what we learned
in the previous talk about negative
regret
so the idea was that
because when you are testing if you
continuously see if you continuously see
that an arm is is worse than another arm
then if it turns out that this arm was
better you have accumulated a lot of
negative regret because this arm has
been worse throughout this whole time so
you can use this negative regret to make
sure that you will do less testing
in in this time if you have already
accumulated enough negative regret and
therefore you are going to do less
exploration which is going to give to
the improved log they compared to the
log squared
yeah sure
so
this delta is the mean of all delta i's
is that significant are you just using
your network i mean yeah in this case
i'm using the mean i believe that the
bounds are not expressed as sums they
are expressed as k over delta
in both cases the delta is the minimum
down so it's not impossible to
get
if you can
against the best arm and expectation in
the stochastic setting uh what does it
mean in the adversarial setting
so remember how we defined the reversing
of the cell case we said
that
the
reward is a function of the entire
system
so essentially if you think about all
the positive histories and based on the
algorithm
they are going to generate histories
right and therefore you can take
expectations with themselves which
has the the largest reward though this
largest expected reward will be the
benchmark to compare the
should regret in the personal case again
this is the comment that hyphen said
before as well this is a function of the
algorithm
case it's not a function of that
okay
another questions
some intuition of what the testing
strategy is in either one of the yeah so
the the things that you typically test
are the following the first one is that
you test so you have created this
interval right for the arm that you're
in
you test that the rewards that you see
are not away from these components in
the
interval
this is one thing that it does and this
is typically mostly what this paper test
this paper also tests whether the reward
that your algorithm is getting
is what you are expecting
based on
based on what you have seen essentially
so also testing whether the arm that you
compare to essentially really uh
satisfies that
then you're like you're not testing the
sub-optimal arms very much
you are you are not testing the sub
you're testing is about him alarms to
make sure that they are still
within their confidence interval
so you want to make sure that
essentially whatever you estimated is
accurate for
the
setting
for the future
that's a high level
and you do that over different intervals
to make sure that all for different
intervals essentially you make you
they they are still
the
the estimate that you created based on
the initial exploration phase is still
a consistent consistent with what you're
seeing
yes
how do you choose which arm to test and
what's the order of the frequency for
such tests
so this is uh
so in this case
in this case for example what you do is
that you have multiple different spaces
once a normal so initially you think
about all the arms happening from your
probability
once an arm is eliminated you decrease
by half the probability if you test it
with this probability now if this thing
has
the same losses it means that you can
make negative regret word space so you
you decrease the probability by half and
this becomes one form
now like if it happens now that these
are not selling now you have guess
positive regret then you say okay we'll
bump up again
to half so that's essentially the scheme
of how to test for example
okay
this is
is it something fundamental do you think
or is it just because they didn't bother
to make it some more
but
i'm not
sure
okay so this is the casting-based
approach
now let's move to the desired-based
approach
so the other cellular base of roots
starts using on the side
like xp3
and
tries to make it to make it attain the
stochastic guarantee square
so the other style based approach
started by the paper from evgeny seldin
and alex slivkins in called 14 and
subsequently
and the gabor lugosi improved the
parameterization in this case then they
proved that it resulted in guarantee
so what are they doing they start with
xp3 which is the algorithm high bank
discussed
and xp3 one version of xp3 mixes with a
uniform distribution to ensure that you
are going to do enough exploration
now
what is the observation in this paper is
that rather than doing a uniform
exploration
you can try to adapt the exploration
that you are doing
on the empirical gap
so if an arm has been worse
you are going to explore it less often
now this is not going to cause a problem
a significant problem because you still
use importance weighted sampling
in
the xp3 algorithm and therefore whenever
you see a high we explore it you're
presumably going to see high lows and
then estimates that you're getting are
unbiased
so this algorithm leads to near optimal
stochastic and adversarial regret
now the optimal guarantees
this is not working
okay now it's working now the optimal
guarantees come from the paper from
a high pang and uh thank you initially
and uh the lia loved my guarantee comes
from simon sardin so and the idea is
that do not use xp3 as your basis uh
adversarial algorithm but rather use
either
chalice or
barrier as we discussed before
and now these algorithms do not do a
direct
gap estimation
but they are exploring significantly
more fast so essentially they end up
identifying the suboptimal alarms
significantly faster so it still is
still the case that the weights of
suboptimal lungs decrease
more starkly and this allows them to get
the
uh
any enhanced guarantee now the analysis
goes by
bounding the regret by a self-bounding
term
and you use this uh this is a unified
analysis because you use the same cell
phone return to bound both to casting an
adversarial case
we are going to have julian zimart
actually in the september workshop he is
going to talk about chalice she will
have 45 minutes to talk about charlie so
i will not give more information about
that now julian zimmer is the author of
this paper he will be in the september
workshop and he will give a 45-minute
talk about a chalice
questions
yes
so just to clarify so the x3 plus plus
and then the sao alger type algorithm
those are both kind of like stitched
together whereas this last one you're
talking about just is an adversarial
algorithm that just naturally also hurts
the captain
essentially in the one case you have a
surprising band gallery but due to tests
in order to switch the adversarial in
the other case you start with another
style language but you place yourself
the exploration how you're going to
explore that according to some
stochastic driven parameters which is
and so it seems unlikely but are there
sort of similarly like any stochastic
algorithms that there's naturally do
okay with adversarial that seems
far-fetched but you know this
cannot really happen because the way
that
the
is that the
stochastic algorithms
end up not selecting
the
the
suboptimal arms after sometimes
you should be for example
deterministically stop selecting even
though something really it has
converged in the situation that the two
are very well separated so you will not
be able to start from
without changing anything and get it
they get it directly
distribution is changing
[Music]
okay what i'm saying is that the cluster
ecb or the classical successful
elimination of the biological uh
thompson sampling that we know
will not
i'm we're not expecting them to give
such a guarantee of course one can
design algorithms that have this
property sales in particular fastest
property okay stochastic
yeah so essentially
uh the the idea of stochastic algorithms
tends to be that you
initially it's not going to identify the
optimal arm
so
this means that you're not going to
select the submarines
of course there may be cases where
one can design more clever algorithms
that have this property and yeah
okay
so this uh completes the first part
where we ask the question of best of
both worlds how can we achieve an
algorithm that simultaneously attains
the stochastic guarantee if the input is
stochastic and also the adversarial
guarantee if the input is adversarial
now what are some challenges that that
exists with
the best of both worlds mindset
first of all if we go to
stochastic-based approaches what they
tend to do is that they switch to xp3 if
they they take non-stochasticity
so even if you have a minor amount of
noise to assist in your data you will go
to some something that is completely
adversarial afterwards
the second challenge is until recently
and this point does not apply to chalice
adversarial-based approaches to analyze
stochastic and adversarial in a
completely in a completely different way
so it's often you will need
you will need to analyze to incorporate
techniques of the one into inside the
others
and finally a point that applies i
believe to all that there are bandit
approaches is that if you go to more
complex settings for example you go to
more difficult feedback structures that
are about binary feedback for example or
you think about other regard structures
that are not decomposable across
elements
it's not clear how you have
a
it's not clear how you get an
adversarial bandit algorithm so it's not
really clear how you are going to even
start an adversarial based approach
because you don't have the adversary the
backbone of the approach that the
scientist
so
this brings us the second to the two
other questions that are
combined the first one is the basing the
two words which says how can we what
models allow us to interpolate between
the stochastic and the desired extreme
and what are design principles that can
adapt to the difficulty of these
settings
and then the
related question is what happens beyond
multi and bandits so
how can we extend such principles to
more complex feedback structures and
more complex
record structures
now in a paper with a hub miracle in the
end of islam a few years ago we
introduced a model of that we call
stochastic bandits with adversarial
corruptions and the idea in this case is
that most of the data are iid
but some rounds are addressable
corrupted
now the example that you should
you can think in online advertising
there's this phenomenon that's called
click through for example where
a an advert an advertiser may create a
boat and deliberately not click some
particular ads of the competitor in
order to make sure that data is going to
be the one that is selected
and so therefore manipulating what the
platform left
if you think about recommender systems
you may have a bunch of different fake
reviews that may affect the estimates
that you're that you're getting
in all of these systems the platforms
tend to try to identify
suspicious successivity so we can expect
that part of the corruption that exists
in the data is going to be identified
but some of it is going to remain
undetected and the question is how can
we make sure to have algorithms that
will be robust to the amount that
remains after that
now what is the formal model
this is exactly the same thing that we
discussed before so the learner selected
distribution ptheatre's arms each arm
gets a reward the learner
randomly selects arma 80
earned the reward of the arm they
selected and observe the reward the
bandit feedback observe the reward of
that arm
now the change that we're introducing is
that we are allowing at this step
an adversary to select whether the round
is going to be corrupted or not
so the adversary selects a
variable c of t that can either be zero
if the round is not corrupted or one if
the round is corrupted and this is an
adaptive adversary similarly to before
they can make the decision as a function
of the entire history until this point
they do not know the realization of this
particular round
similar to the the adversarial case but
they know the algorithm and they know
whatever happened in previous rounds
now the reward
is either drawn from the stochastic
distribution if the round is not
corrupted
or it is coming from
this
or it's coming from an adaptive
adversary that can depend to the entire
on the entire history if the round is
corrupted
in other than that the same is
completely is exactly the same
so does the model
make sense of course
so it's exactly the same thing as before
we allow an adversary to corrupt or not
and if the round is corrupted then you
see an iid draw from the fixed
distribution if the round isn't is if
it's not corrupted if it is corrupted
then it comes from an adaptive adversary
one can define this uh one can define
this presentation by allowing
that by talking about guarantees that
will scale with the amount of corruption
that existed but this is the simpler way
to to present this case where an entire
round is corrupted
so
we're saying for series
[Music]
this is a one way to
formally define what an adaptive
adversary means
that the directive adversary selects a
potentially randomized function that
depends on the exact whatever has
happened until this point for any
possible trajectory of whatever has
happened until this point they select a
randomized the distribution so if a
randomized reward so if in that sense
they sound from this case but it's not a
fixed distribution
it's just a formal way to define
what an adopted person means in this
case
no there is but they are allowed towards
what i'm saying yeah
yeah so i was just wondering like if i
think of observation error
uh i would think that you observe
incorrectly but the reward is what
is the real reward
uh so
the observation would be the corrupted
one
most of the results covering dependence
on c anyway okay so if you think about
because we bounded which we are assuming
then the bound will be the same in this
case both settings make sense like for
effective use you don't really care
the extra linear c if
if the corruption only appears in the
feedback uh the way that you measure
regret uh
you just don't pick up any corruption at
all
yeah what i'm saying is that if you have
a guarantee that anyway has a linear
dependency
now we are going to discuss that in
settings in the code
objective in this objective one can
actually achieve
in some cases guarantees that i do not
have to clean that
while the linear dependence on c is
unavoidable if you think about them
because it could be that they decide
so the goal is to design an algorithm or
general design principles that adopt the
number of graphic rounds so capital c
will be this the total number of rounds
that are productive
now what i will try to do in most of the
rest of the tool
is to discuss
three main techniques
that achieve
such uh uh such a nice uh
such a nice interpolation such
guarantees that will be robust to ac
that adapt to this amount of corruption
uh yes
yeah so again yeah i meant this comment
before uh so the
in for this talk for the purpose of this
talk and also in many other settings if
you think where there is no scalar
notion that is associated you need to
define c as a as the number of corrupted
rounds in multi and bondage or
reinforcement learning you can actually
define them as l1 norm between the iid
draw and the the resulting corrupted
throw
uh okay so the first algorithm is uh the
initial algorithm that we introduced in
the paper with ahab and renato that has
a log square guarantee which if you
remember it's similar with what the sao
algorithm was having for high
probability and we said in this case
that log squared is not improvable for
the best of both worlds case we have a
similar lower bound that actually shows
that it's not improvable in the
corrupted case if you care about high
probability guarantees it has a
dependence on c is c times k
times log d over gap this is the
stochastic case
now there was a follow-up paper by an
pam actually and uh
colin and talvar that
achieves that moves the ck outside so
you have ck plus the summation of log
squared
over a gap
and it's also a high probability
guarantee and lastly there is the
charlie sympho algorithm and the
charisma algorithm achieves a guarantee
that is the stochastic guarantee
plus a term the square root of c
times this
and essentially as you see if you think
about the gap being
being fixed for example this allows you
to get something that would be square
root of t in the worst case so actually
it's alice achieves a complete
interpolation between the two settings
it does do that for the pseudoregret
guarantee and it does not extend for too
high probability to the best of my
knowledge but achieves this
interpolation between the two between
the two extremes
now
i will discuss all of this approaches in
more detail and compare them and also
discuss in which settings the one is
more useful than the other
but first of all let's start by the
point that we discussed before about why
stochastic approaches
fail
um
21 that improves a little bit this
dependence inside
and there's a paper by ito
in
eurips 21 that also provides another
rather improvement in additional
improvement i'm not sure if they
resolved the lobby but there have been
some results afterwards that improve
essentially some of the dependents
inside here
i'm i'm not i'm not completely sure
whether the logitech has been
has been removed though
somehow all these results only depend on
the number of corrupted points that
don't depend on like
you know the actual character of the
sequence
like if it appears like
once or something like that yeah and all
of this is not in reality would only
depend
on the amount on the one distance
between the corrupted reverse and the
actual network so
in reality it's even more defined but
they do not have to they do not make any
assumption about when production
this gives me a good breeze because
we're talking about breathing here
to discuss uh what uh how why the
societal approaches are
because exactly this
if you were an investor in this setting
and you wanted to attack a certain
button algorithm like successive
elimination what would you do
so one thing that you can do is that you
can code up the exploration rounds
so the successive elimination really in
the beginning just selects all the arms
and try to create confidence intervals
just corrupt these logarithmic rounds in
the beginning
and then what you got
is that
you return for the optimal alarm records
of zero
so you believe that this arm is really
suboptimal it really has a mean of zero
so what breaks here from the previous
analysis that the actual mean is not now
inside the confidence interval
and after logarithmic number of rounds
we actually deactivate the optimal arms
which means that with only a logarithmic
amount of corruption we cause linear
regression
so this is a challenge essentially and
this brings back to the question about
like
this this model allows us to corrupt any
arbitrary part of the of the sequence in
particular
for classical stochastic algorithms this
typically would be in the rounds that
are more exploratory
does it make sense this example so
essentially what you're going to do if
you know that an algorithm does explodes
and this exploits is just corrupt all
the exploration make the learner believe
that the optimal alarm is really
suboptimal
the the learner will stop selecting this
arm from then onwards and then you're
going to continue and you're going to
have the learner get
a linear regret like constant regret
every round so this will mean linear
regret in total
now
the idea that we're having in what we
call multi-layering successive
elimination rays
is that let's start from a simpler case
where you know how much corruption
exists
in
how much corruption that versa is going
to put
let's say for example that the vessel is
only going to put a logarithmic amount
of corruption
now if you knew that the adversary
this is something that we're going to
remove afterwards but let's assess
experiment let's assume that we knew
that the adversary really is not is only
going to put up the logarithmic number
of grounds
so this is similar to the attack that we
said before right the address i only
corrupted logarithmic number of rounds
big in the beginning and then we learned
something completely long
so what can we do in this case well we
could update our bonus to take into
account the corruption
so you just add a term that sees a
c bar over the number of rounds of
number of players which means that even
if the adversary was putting all the
corruption on exploration rounds
you still have this buffer that allows
you to make sure that you're not going
to
to get penalized by that
now
this and if you think about the regret
because we said that the c bar is a
logarithmic amount then you had a
logarithm you added one more logarithm
so you lose one constant but
the regret guarantee is the same
of course this can only handle a
logarithmic amount of corruption and
that's not what i promised you
so the idea in order to extend that to
the unknown corruption setting
is to create multiple independent copies
of successive elimination each of switch
will be responsible for a corruption for
a different corruption level
so the health copy is going to be
responsible for a corruption level of 2
to the l
so you have this log t different
algorithms that run independently and
each of them is responsible for a
corruption level of 2 to there
now at any round you are going to select
the health copy with probability 2 to
the minus l
now
if the copy
is uh and you're only going to update
the estimates for this particular for
this the confidence interval for this
particular copy you're not going to
to
do any update in any of the other
algorithms
now if it was the case that
the
the index of the the copy was above look
c
it means that you're selecting this
probability two to the minus l
so if the total corruption is c
then the expected corruption that you're
going to see at this particular copy is
c times two to the minus self which is
less than one and with high probability
is less than log t
but we know how to make an algorithm
robust i love the amount so all these
copies are fine they are slower because
you are selecting them through ability
to do the minor cell so they are going
to take two to the l time longer in
order to identify the arm a star the
optimal arm but they are going to
identify that and they're not going to
be fooled by the corruption
now the smaller copies the else that are
less than lopsi will be prone to
corruption for the same reason that we
discussed before
so the the challenge that exists is how
can we have arrays across these copies
that combines the learning speed of the
past
layers
with the robustness from the other ones
and the idea is that we're going to use
the robust copies to supervise the
faster ones and one way to do so is that
if at any point a robust copy tells you
that an arm is a bottomal you transfer
this information to all the copies that
are above them because you should not
trust them more than the robust copy one
thing that can happen is that a copy now
may have zero active arms in which case
you will just go to the first and the
the first copy that has active arms and
you're going to use that in this case
so this is what we call nested
eliminations
and
essentially by doing so
the number of rounds that a suboptimal
arm is going to survive is dictated by
the first robust copy
because at some point the first robust
copy is going to eliminate this arm or
deactivating the language that i used
before and the from then onwards no copy
before it is going to select it
afterwards so the regret that you're
getting is c times the regret of the
fastest lubus copy and the fast the rate
of the faster robust copy is locked the
other gut so that's how you get this
multiplicative dependence on c
and the reason why you get the low
square dependence is because you unlock
t copies and this of them is going to
accumulate log t over gap if there was
no corruption so that's how you get look
log square t plus c
over gap
c log d over dot
so this is a high level idea about how
this approach works
but let's try to think about what what
we really did in this case
we had a problem that can be solved
by estimating the ground rules the
ground truth was
then the arm that is the optimal arm
so there was another highest mean than
other arms and we tried to estimate what
is this optimal arm
then we had an algorithm
that worked by
aggressively refining
some active confidence set this was the
set of arms that were not deactivated
and this algorithm is the successful
elimination algorithm
now the first step that we did is that
we made this robust
a collapsible level of lock t which was
very simple in multiple bandits and then
we had this multi-layering idea
where we run independent log
team-dependent copies of this algorithm
and we used
robust copies to supervise non-robust
copies
the way that we phrase that is actually
more general recipe it is not only
applicable to multiple bandwidths in a
paper with hara for the mata and also
accessibility and drop zapier we use the
same recipe for the setting of
contextual pricing
where
the setting is that there is a customer
that has a value that is the inner
product between a ground truth with a
star and the context 60 which is
potentially adversarial
and the algorithm that we're using in
this case the paper is an algorithm by
ilan and renadopa islam and adrian vlado
which is called projected volume which
is a cutting plane algorithm essentially
and the challenge in this setting is
because you have adversarial context you
only receive and you only receive binary
feedback you only learn whether the
value was above or below the price that
you selected
then you don't really you cannot really
use algorithms like for example the
middle descent algorithms that we
discussed before because you don't see
that you cannot create an important
weighted estimator for example in this
setting
so
in this case actually the most
challenging component is to actually
create this algorithm the algorithm that
will be robust to a log the amount of
corruption and
actually
okay
okay and actually hara is going to
discuss that in the september workshop
and also has a follow-up paper in call
22 that
improves
the guarantee that we're providing for
some settings
of the contextual pricing problem so if
you want to learn more about this result
in the september workshop you will hear
her talk about it
now
when we go so what was the external
recipe we had a problem that worked by
estimating the ground rules this was the
optimal arm in multiple bandits it was
theta star which is a theta star you can
think of it as
how it's a vector that says how valuable
its features is so you can think of it
as a
object where its indexes corresponds to
a different feature and the
theta i starts as how how valuable it is
for the customer to have this
this particular feature
so the algorithms is effectively were
successful elimination protected volume
and we use the same idea here
in both settings there are other papers
so for example there is an algorith
result for assortment optimization by 10
is a museum one that is actually
building on the conservers algorithm
that we discussed before the mnl bandit
algorithm
this is the the sim the algorithm that
works by refining active config sets and
also there is a result for product
rankings for example that is building on
an
algorithm for product tracking that does
not that is uncorrupted
so this is about multi-layering
successive elimination race let's move
to barbara which is the second algorithm
so
if you think about if you
recall what the the multi uh
multilayering successive elimination
days do
it have this multiple copies and you run
them in parallel so so you are selecting
the copy l with probability to the minor
cell they were running in parallel and
at some point
some of the moreover copies were
supervising the less robust copies
and the corruption was subsampled
because if you are a copy that has
largely you are only observing
in the rounds that are corrupted you are
only observing that probability demand
yourself
so the observation that anupam and
tomer and kunal
had
was to try to instead of having this
algorithm in parallel work with e-books
that are geometrically increasing
and
if the input is complete stochastic
actually you can think of such
algorithms as in its epoch in the health
epoch you are aiming to identify all the
suboptimal alarms that have gap less
than two to the minus sign
now
the idea was that instead of eliminating
suboptimal alarms
what barbara is going to do is that it's
going to select them with probability
that is inverse to the empirical gap in
the previous epoch
so it works in epoch at any epoch you
only care about what happened in the
last epoch
so based on that you compute empirical
means and therefore empirical gaps and
you're selecting them
each arm with probability inversely
depending on this empirical
empirical gap
now the idea is that essentially this is
also subsampling corruption because if
the adversary put all this effort and
make sure that you realize that an army
is optimal
in a particular epoch then you're going
to select it with very low probability
so they need to put even more effort in
the next round to
to fool you again
and by doing this i this and by using
this idea actually they are able to get
this additive dependence of ck rather
than the multiplicative that uh we
discussed before
third algorithm
so again as we discussed uh uh before
the
analysis of challenging
works by bounding the regret by a
self-bounding term which is optimal for
it that gives optimal stochastic and
versailles to the regret
now the same analysis actually can use
in the presence of the cellular
corruptions and it can uh
you can bound this term
by also
adjusting to corruptions if they exist
and uh so as we discussed before this
actually is strengthened
subsequently in subsequent papers and as
high bank already discussed this axle
can extend to other settings as well
such as combinatorial bandits and
reinforcement learning because it can be
used as building glob block with other
regularizers also using block barriers
as well in many of them
as again as i said julian is going to
give a talk about sally's in detail in
the september workshop so i'm not going
to discuss
more about this now
but i would like to compare the three
techniques because i think they have
different values in different settings
so what is the multi-layering successive
elimination rates do it tells you that
any setting where you have an algorithm
that works with confidence sets
you can it doesn't matter whether it has
binary feedback or it has
it doesn't have an address
analog and adversarial algorithm if it
operates with confidence sets and it
refines the confidence sets as what
successive elimination does or projected
volume or mnl bandit or
different algorithms or different
settings
then you can apply the recipe that we
discussed and obtain high probability
guarantee
at the cost of a multiplicative
dependence on the number of corrupted
rounds
now the barber algorithm has a very
elegant corruption sampling technique as
we discussed before because it doesn't
just run the algorithms completely
in parallel which can lead to something
that can be wasteful but rather it uses
this uh
samples with probability that is inverse
to the empirical gap and therefore
ensures that the adversary cannot
corrupt a particular arm without putting
without suspending uh too much uh
corruption budget and also leads to high
probability guarantee
that said the drawback of this approach
that you kind of need some notion of gap
in many settings you don't have a
natural notion of gap in order to be
able to sample with probability that
will be inverse to the empirical gap in
the contextual pricing setting for
example is not there is no clear way of
what the gap would mean in this case
finally the talism achieves a nice
interpolation between the two extremes
so actually when the c is equal to t you
get the square root of t guarantee up to
a logic term that we may be able to
resolve whether it can be
removable
but it requires to have a way to do
importance weighting
so it requires to be able to say to
decompose the regard that you're getting
in elements where you can apply
importance waiting
and so it it's not clear how it will go
to adapt to settings like binary
feedback or when you don't have a finite
set of policies
as an example let's think about what
happens in episode karel and we're going
to discuss that in more we're going to
discuss reinforcement learning in more
detail uh tomorrow
but so we have a follow-up paper with
maxim koitz alex livkins and when sun
where we use the idea of multi-layering
active illumination rays actually we use
it with a usb algorithm because
we do not know successive elimination
versions in reinforcement learning
because those will suffer with in
exponential to the episode horizon
and we provide guarantees that apply to
tabular mdp's linear mdps gap-based
results so for any setting that you have
an uncorrupted setting you can have an
analog for the other setting
that said it leads to multiplicative
dependence on the number of corrupted
rounds
now there's another paper by chen du and
jameson that builds on barbar it
achieves a dependence that is again
additive on the corrupted rounds but
only applies to tabular mtps because
there you can create gaps so it cannot
extend to linear mdps and does not give
gap dependent guarantees
and finally in charlie synth
i believe that we one can achieve a
perfect interpolation for rewards so for
if the losses or rewards can be
stochastic adversarial or corrupted you
can achieve essentially a perfect
interpolation that says it requires the
transitions to not be corrupted because
if the transitions are corrupted you
cannot use importance waiting as well
the way that reinforcement learning
works is that you work with key
functions so in some way you need to be
able to create an unbiased estimator
about the q function of the particular
action at a particular state and if you
don't have a good idea about what is the
uh the future the transitions uh this is
not uh
easily amenable
so this this gives an idea about the
different
the settings they i said in the
different regimes where the results
apply and also
uh in which settings one you should
think about using one algorithm compared
to another
a very interesting thing that i would
like to also mention is that there are
situations where you have a symbiosis of
these techniques
so for example there is a person paper
by 10 and 1 which i really liked which
tries to do learning with inventory
constraints
now when you have inventory constraints
you have two problems that you need to
understand first of all you need to
understand
what is the price that will have you
deplete your inventory
so this is a binary sales problem in
some sense
on the other hand you also would need to
understand what's the most profitable
the most profitable uh
price that you could select so this is a
multi-unbounded problem because you can
think of different prices as different
terms
now if you use alisynth
as we discussed this will not work with
the binaries search type of approach so
you cannot solve the inventory question
directly at least with a talisman but if
you use multi-layering successive
elimination rays you're going to get
some optimal guarantee because the
number of arms in this case is something
like
square root of t for example or to the
thirds in these settings because you
need to discretize the space essentially
and if you have a
multiplicative dependence on on top of
that then you may have uh
you may have significantly goes
guarantees
that said
in binary cell you get log t so
multi-layering active illumination
raised to successful elimination rays
actually achieves c times log t for the
binary sets problem
so what segment one provides is an
algorithm that combines the two
techniques and uses multi-layering
successive elimination rays in order to
solve the binary search problem which is
the inventory problem while using uh the
chalice info in order to solve the
inventory in order to solve the
selecting the price question the most
profitable
price question which is a
multi-unbounded problem so there are
situations where actually it's not that
you need to choose but you may want to
think about how you can combine the
different techniques
based on
particular characteristics that your
setting has
now
another
now
i will one other point that i would like
to mention is that one way to view those
corruptions is also as a model selection
problem
if you think about what multi
layering race is doing is it has all
these different layers and this of these
layers is responsible for a corruption
level of two to the l
so in some sense you can think of them
as different models
and you would like to go to understand
which model you should trust essentially
which model to select to use
and actually it doesn't work by changing
way and chris don and julian siemen
actually makes this connection explicit
and uses
the
episodical work that we had
in order by a model selection to provide
an improvement for the corrupted rl uh
problem and this builds on a model
selection approach that hyphen had we
send you
for non-stationary rl and again i'm
going to advertise that send your uh is
going to present this work in the
september workshop so stay come again
in the in the september workshop this
will be it has very
many very nice talks
uh
and uh
now i promise you that i will not only
talk about corruption so another way
that i only briefly mentioned two other
ways to interpolate between stochastic
and underserved case
one way is to think about the memory of
the adversary so what do we do say we
say that the stochastic case is
that the input is completely id this was
this was coming from a
regular distribution f well in the other
case it was a function of the whole
history so there are recent works that
try to say that the adversary can only
use the last m
observations for example they have a
memory of the m
and this makes sense in periodic in sec
cases that they have periodicity for
example
maybe you you really care about things
maybe it's not the case that you're
completely id but you depend essentially
with some way on some of the past rounds
but you don't depend on everything
so there are some results on that line
of work by video and co-authors
and video will be here in the september
workshop and she's going to talk both
about this and about generally modern
selection
in such
settings
finally i would like to briefly mention
one recent work that we have that also
bridges between stochastic and
adversarial
so in many cases the rewards that you
are getting
is not are not completely coming from an
adversary but rather come from agents
that have their own utility function
they really have some particular
objective and they try to maximize their
individual objective so if you think
about pricing
the
an agent will buy if their value is
above the price they're not going to
just select the
responses to make you have the lowest
possible uh
the lowest possible
reward
so these are typically captured well by
principal agent or cycle bed games
in a cycle break game what happens is
that the a principal initially commits
to on a randomized action that i denote
by xc and subsequently there isn't best
response according to their own payoff
metrics so the principal has a payoff
metrics the agent has another payoff
matrix
and there are multiple results so for
learning instagram games so in this case
the principal does not know the agent's
payoff metrics
and tries to learn it on the fly so they
select actions they observe best
responses from the agent they continue
by trying to
get
as much
reward as possible
there are multiple settings like
cycle-based security games the pricing
can be written within a non-demand curve
can be written as
such associations that this
classification
has very nice work so in
in that
direction
now a crucial assumption that these
models tend to do is that they assume
that the agent is completely myopic they
assume that the agent will completely
best respond according to this to based
on this their behavioral model
but if you think about settings that are
sequential they then may decide to
sacrifice some of the present utility
in order to get something better in the
future
so this assumption that the agent is
completely best responding often is not
something that holds in practice
so
in a paper with nikah talaba and sloan
itard and alex way we address how to
think about learning with non-myopic
withdrawal myopic agents one typical
model about non-myopia is that the agent
is discounting the future
so
the agent has a discount factor and the
total utility that they are getting is
a discounted sum of
the future rewards
and this if you think about this again
interpolation between stochastic and
versa
if the disk if there is no if the agent
doesn't value the future at all this is
exactly the best responsibility which is
stochastic case
is the agent is infinitely patient then
this is a case which is completely
adversarial and typically you have false
theorems that say that bad things happen
in such cases
now the approach that we're following is
that
we try to establish a bleeds again
towards the theme of this
of this talk
so we try to establish an information
screen that we slow down the reactions
of the reaction that we have to agents
responses
so this can be happened one way that
this can happen is by delaying how you
are going to
how you are going to incorporate the
feedback that you get from the agents
as a result if you delay enough
this will mean that the agent will not
have a big incentive they will not have
incentive to largely deviate they are
not going to do arbitrary actions they
are only going to do actions that are
approximate based responses
and then we need to design minimally
minimally reactive algorithms that are
robust to such approximate best
responses and we will do that for all
the settings that i discussed before for
starting by security games actually we
also achieve an optimal algorithm for
learning even with the myopic case on
the way
and uh then to be able to again do that
for an unknown discount factor we use
the multi-layering grades that i
discussed before to adapt to an unknown
discount factor so you don't assume that
you know what is the discount factor
that the agent is using
and sloan is likely going to present a
poster
of this work in the september workshops
so feel free to to to see his poster
this gives me a good opportunity to
actually remind everybody that we will
have a poster session on the september
gossip and
and the deadline is on friday it is for
students and postdocs so if you are a
student post or postdoc submit your work
if you are not a student postdoc tells
your students and post experience to
submit works
we
we are going we get some visuals until
this friday and we're planning to make
decisions by next tuesday so that we
tell people to book flights and
accommodation
so to sum up
what we discussed in this talk
we talked how we took the stochastic
extreme from zebra stock and we took the
adversarial extreme from hypenstock and
we discussed how one can try to create
bridges between the stochastic and
adversarial worlds
we started from best of both worlds
which was the question of how can one
design a single algorithm that
simultaneously achieves the stochastic
guarantee when they input the stochastic
and the adversarial guarantee when they
input this adversarial we discuss said
that there are two ways to do that there
is the stochastic based approaches that
start from a stochastic algorithm tests
on the way and if they detect some
non-stochasticists to completely switch
to an adversarial
and there is adversarial-based
approaches that start from the other
side algorithm and try to somehow
do
to adapt their exploration based on
empirical gov for example or do
something else that will allow them to
achieve a better guarantee in the
stochastic setting
then we moved away from the two extremes
and we've discussed how to bridge the
two walls
and with this briefly we mostly talked
about adversarial corruptions as a way
to bridge those two but we also briefly
discussed memory of adversary and
discount factor for non-myopic learning
agents as other ways that one can try to
go between stochastic and versailles
four other channel corruptions we'll
discuss the three approaches the
multi-layering successive elimination
base the barbar and the chalice synth
and we've discussed different uh
advantages of different of these
approaches potential drawbacks that this
of them has in situations where actually
you need to have a symbiosis situations
where you actually need to use both of
them in order to address your problem
and finally we've discussed what happens
beyond you try to move beyond the simple
multi-budget setting and we saw for
example that multi-layering race
achieves it has a general recipe that
applies to contextual pricing and
non-myopic learning as we said here
assortment optimization
product rankings and generally any
problem where you have you can create a
conf you have an algorithm that works by
refining a
confidence set that includes a ground
route
we also saw that challenging is
extendable in some settings and this is
mostly settings in which you can create
unbiased estimates by important weights
for example combinatorial symbian but
it's reinforcement learning with iid
transitions so so uh and we also saw
that this can be used
in part as one of the building blocks
for to deal with pricing with inventory
constraints in the symbiosis discussion
and uh
lastly we said that sometimes actually
having the symbiosis is useful so there
are situations where you do not need to
choose but you need to choose which part
you are going to take from from each of
the opportunities
and with that i would like to thank you
and i am very excited about this
semester
[Applause]
for advertising the next workshop um we
have time for like one or two small
questions are there any
can you give some information as to what
the hard instances look like for
different corruption levels so is there
some general structure
like so i guess like hyping for example
was talking about like the hard instance
for
this standard bandwidth is these two
arms getting closer to each other
then you have if i fix that eruption
level is there some intuition as to what
is the
instance like what's the structure of
that
so you may not what would be the
level what's the hardest problem
with the lower bound instance
yeah i mean i do not know i would assume
that this is where they learned with
this version of c i don't know how this
would look like but i would assume that
will be similar with the main marks
for the other side uh
for the high probability results the
lower bound that we are providing is
very similar to the one that our scan is
doing and in this case you have
essentially you have two arms where
the
you have one or two words
and essentially you
in you need to get c
c
c c c regret
uh if you are in the one word but uh
like i said the optimal thing for the
one word would be you to select
and one arm half of the times for the
initial stereo system that's so that's
why you get the
the lower bound for the high probability
guarantee
okay is there a burning question left
you have to stand
okay well the great thing is that the
horses around you guys are around so you
can have more discussions thank you so
much thank you so much
so we are starting tomorrow at 9 30
again and
is there a
there's a reception right now okay we'll
see you in the reception and then again
tomorrow morning thank you